lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en diferentes maneras de
representar el cambio de la posición de
un objeto a través del tiempo una de las
maneras básicas es mediante una tabla
por ejemplo aquí en la columna izquierda
tenemos el tiempo probablemente en
segundos y en la columna derecha tenemos
la posición que puede estar dada en
cualquier unidad digamos que en metros
así que en el tiempo cero estamos en
tres después de un segundo seguimos
estando en tres después de dos segundos
estamos en uno negativo después de tres
segundos estamos en cero después de
cuatro segundos estamos en cero
seguimos en cero y después de cinco
segundos estamos en dos probablemente
dos metros ahora esto es algo útil pero
es un poco difícil de visualizar
y esto no nos dice qué es lo que está
pasando entre cada uno de estos momentos
qué es lo que está pasando en la mitad
de un segundo simplemente no nos movimos
y nuestra posición no cambió o si cambio
y luego volvimos a tener la misma
posición no lo sabemos si tenemos una
tabla como esta pero otra forma de
pensar en esto podría hacer con una
animación por ejemplo digamos que
tenemos nuestra recta numérica y digamos
que el objeto que estamos moviendo es un
limón así que cuando el tiempo es cero
empezamos en la posición 3 aquí donde
está el limón y veamos si podemos
animarlo voy a tratar de contar 5
segundos y de mover el limón de acuerdo
con lo que tenemos en la tabla de
posición contra tiempo o de tiempo
contra posición cero
entonces esto resulta útil pero tal vez
sería más útil graficar esto de manera
que no tengamos que estar mirando la
animación sino que podamos ver qué pasa
a través del tiempo
para eso podemos construir lo que
llamamos una gráfica de posición contra
tiempo
típicamente el tiempo está en el eje
horizontal y la posición está en el eje
vertical así que vamos a pensar en esto
un poco cuando nuestro tiempo es igual a
cero nuestra posición es igual a tres
nuestro tiempo es igual a cero y la
posición es igual a tres luego cuando
nuestro tiempo es igual a 1 nuevamente
estamos en 3 cuando el tiempo es igual a
2 la posición es igual a 1 negativo
cuando el tiempo es igual a 2 la
posición es 1 negativo cuando el tiempo
es igual a 3
nuestra posición es igual a 0 nuestra
posición es cero recuerden aunque aquí
estábamos pensando en posiciones de
derecha e izquierda acá nuestra posición
es hacia arriba y hacia abajo entonces
nuestra posición es igual a cero cuando
el tiempo es igual a 3 luego cuando el
tiempo es igual a 4 nuestra posición
sigue siendo 0 y luego cuando nuestro
tiempo es igual a 5
nuestra posición es igual a 2
así que nuestro primer segundo no tengo
un cambio en la posición o al menos es
lo que yo supuse cuando anime limón y
luego al pasar del primer segundo al
segundo segundo mi posición cambio de
tres a uno negativo
de 3 a 1 negativo
y si hacemos esto a una tasa constante
esto sería una línea como esta
y luego del tiempo 2 al 3 pasamos de la
posición 1 negativo a la posición 0
aquí pasar de uno negativo a cero
representa un movimiento de uno a la
derecha pero aquí como estamos
graficando la posición en el eje
vertical esto se ve como un movimiento
hacia arriba pero simplemente es pasar
de uno negativo a 0 del segundo 2 al
segundo 3 ahora de 3 a 4 nuestra
posición no cambia por la manera en que
lo estamos representando y luego del
tiempo 4 al 5
nuestra posición pasa de 0 a 2 de 0 a 2
y entonces a lo que construimos aquí se
le llama gráfica de posición contra
tiempo y a partir de esta gráfica sin
necesidad de una animación podemos
entender inmediatamente cómo cambia
nuestra posición a través del tiempo así
que hagamos nuestra animación una vez
más y tratemos de seguir la posición en
la gráfica de posición contra tiempo tal
vez un poco más despacio entonces para
el primer segundo me voy a quedar en la
misma posición y empezaré a contar
luego nuestra posición cambia a uno
negativo para el siguiente segundo
[Música]
y 5
espero que hayan podido apreciar que
esta es una forma rápida de ver lo que
está pasando y terminamos